mes cheveux ils sont riches obama ils
sont méchants vos cheveux ils font
n'importe quoi je leur parle plus au
genre du cerveau elle parle plus à ses
cheveux moi je parle pas à mes choux
habituellement mais chacun son truc là
en l'occurrence elle ne parle plus à ses
cheveux parce qu'ils sont méchants du
coup ils doivent bouder non ça fait
comment des cheveux qui boudent malick
bâ genre ils font comme ça oui que non
[Musique]
non si rien
c'est qu'on emploie pas en tapant
away
c'est là tu fais quoi tu compte pas
c'est pourquoi
franchement à
trois mâts
j'ai pas vu les gens et jara plaisir ça
me connaissez beaucoup d'émissions télé
où on vendait des toilettes c'est la
première fois des expertises des
toilettes merci à porter cet objet
délicat yade ou de genève d'un hôtel
particulier oui qui a été démontée dans
les années 1960 et qu'une personne m'a
donné l' avantage que ma maman travaille
dans une station service elle me ramène
énormément de rouleaux de papier wc
relativement épais j'ai cru qu'ils
allaient bien et me ramène de l'essence
alors leur a dit vous avez de la chance
oui oui vous en auriez voulu aussi ma
faute comme tout le monde dort aura bien
les saints lors des papes du haut des
rouleaux de papier toilette oui et avec
ça j'ai fait des calendriers de l'avent
à parce que là en fait il reste encore
10 minutes à peu près sur lot 6 à 7 tu
veux pas c'est plutôt sûreté pmp
alors comme ça et c'est bien c'est ok tu
vois pour le pour ce conte des facs de
ton salaire
fabrice comptes à ok
et donc non n'avait pas l'usagé
on a tous les âges vous n'osez pas vous
en servir j'ai rarement mais il est
fonctionnel mais ce n'est pas une boîte
aux lettres du mouvement
magnifique 500 porcelaine c'est en
porcelaine en porcelaine anglaise alors
on va soulever la lunette pour pour
découvrir
pour déjà arrivé d'expertisé de salaire
c'est la première fois de ma vie
évidemment même si 93 pour cent de la
population gagne moins que ça je suis
désolé on n'est pas riche quand on à
3673 euros par mois être riche cette
fortune et sait mettre énormément
d'argent de côté sécurisé d'ayem
plusieurs bien c'est pouvoir aller au
restaurant quand on veut c'est voyager
quand on veut et je suis désolé quand on
gagne cette somme là pour moi qu'on paye
un loyer qu'on a des charges et qu'on a
un train de vie normal justement on a un
train de vie normal et on ne peut pas se
permettre de vivre de manière superflu
celle ci c'est l'une des mes paires de
chaussures les plus chers j'ai mis tout
mon salaire sur cette paire de choses
complètement débiles de mettre autant
dans une paire de chaussures surtout
pour une paire pas confortable c'est
vraiment complètement pas se cacher vous
malpoli c'est le moment de jouer parce
que toute la semaine on vous offre le
salaire du député souvenez vous on vous
a offert le salaire du président abbas
est semaines semaines des législatives
oblige on vous a vu le salaire de votre
député 5700 euros voilà ce qu'ils vont
gagner nos députés bien pour gagner le
salaire du député vous envoyer le 7 32
16 o le sel ne vous en voyez salaire est
pas récente de 16 à partir de 490 mille
euros de patrimoine on est considéré
comme riche et ensuite une deuxième
chose me tao ici moi je gagne 1500 euros
par mois mais j'ai avec quelqu'un comme
pinault arnault hanouna à ce moment là
est ce que je suis riche mais ce que je
suis paris
[Applaudissements]
inquiétez pas les sorties d'elle même
celle là qui sonne love les filles insel
l'homme là encore c'est presque ça rame
un pin celle-là pin's and love non c'est
peace and love un pay amour en anglais à
rama vous allez nous régaler cette
semaine avec votre pin's
pix'n love
peace and love ce week-end la ville de
sabre et saint brieuc a battu un record
du monde mais lequel
sage non saint brieuc la grêle des
crêpes est ce que vous voulez un petit
indice ouais on écoute la plus grande
la plus grande folie du monde oui ou non
sens la plus grande chenille qui
redémarre du monde on peut voir les
images sur m6 story
1338 personnes ont participé à cette
chenille humaine géante
malika où c'est le thème style avec une
robe bohème qui vous laisse sans voix
réservé à ce que savait le cerveau m
comment ça tu sais pas ce que c'est le
style bohème à l'écart taka censé être
le top de la mode ah là là ça va pas bah
oui malika bohème franchement ça vous
fait penser à rien ça me fait penser à
aux hippies ben oui c'est ça la raison
plus épices
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est rigolo
potache mais aussi
fait sa spéciale art rock et tu veux
aussi que les gens y vote après carter
sont les mêmes qui ne sont les mêmes
champs droits de vote monsieur pour vous
c'était qu'à l'époque les pipis
c'est à dire quelle guerre première
ola lalla malika
côté du pont pas